this is the Arc de Triomphe it's not a  really a very good copy of the Italian  arch I wouldn't say anything to the  French because they like their actions  very much and they would feel really bad  if they knew this is a poor cop and now  we need to get organized here is there  maybe something you wanted to give me  with a be one room or two five this guy  is possessed me completely make the girl  on a bicycle but there's gotta be  someone not gonna be able to take care  of you on the kids give someone from  Facebook Bernie Papa  Bonjour he's too worried wanna go  jogging ah I was in the mouth of the  Dragon then I used my feet like this and  my arms like this  sorry on toda la Mancha ray of Annette  do look with aliens laughter everyone  the hit in a traffic accident they would  have twice the population of China  Cecile Afghanistan has to finish sex you  have to finish Italian men's think that  fidelity is the name of the woman who  lives across the hall  you